Are you ready?
Yes, I am.
[music playing]
It will--
[metal clangs]
WIL WILLIS: The Zande spear.
Ooh, boy!
WIL WILLIS (VOICEOVER): One
of the deadliest weapons used
by the Zande tribes
of Central Africa,
the Zande spear was
used for fighting as
well as for hunting.
Known throughout history
as conquering warriors,
the Zande exhibited unmatched
skills on the battlefield.
Affixed to a wooden
shaft, the spear
was suitable for throwing and
attacking from long distances.
But its thrusting
ability made it
just as effective as
a close-combat weapon.
The sharp upper and lower
tines and multiple spikes
inflicted deadly wounds,
both upon entry and exit
from the victim's body.
The Zande's lethal
use of the spear
can be seen highlighted in
the game "Deadliest Warrior."
Bladesmiths, I will
take your Zande spear
and deliver killing blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Drew, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's make those
intestines out-testines.
All right.
[laughs] Let's do that.
I like that.
DREW (VOICEOVER): Right now,
I'm about to hear Doug say,
"It will kill."
And that's the only
thing I'm here for.
To help me out today, please
welcome back RJ Marcaida.
He will have the pleasure of
wielding your Zande spear.
[music playing]
[laughter]
All right, Drew.
It feels very good in the hand.
It lacerates deep.
When we thrust this into the
chest cavity, into the heart,
on its way out, not only does
it take some skin with it,
but it also took out some ribs.
Your tines right here from
the side entry, the spear
went all the way through.
And on its way out,
it took everything
that was in its path.
But there is one issue.
As you can see, your tip
right here broke off.
But other than that, this
is a weapon that is deadly,
and it will KEAL.
Thank you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Jason, your turn.
You ready?
I know it'll cut.
[laughs]
[music playing]
All right, Jason.
The balance of your
weapon feels good.
When it penetrated into the
chest cavity, it hit a rib
and broke it in half.
Got into the heart, and there
was no edge damage on your tip.
All these hooks
right here did what
it's supposed to do--
into the abdomen,
ripped everything
out, even the barb.
And the beautiful thing
about this is it will KEAL.
That's what I wanted to hear.
Say hello to my
little friend here.
Today, we're going to
test the overall strength
and construction of
your Zande spears by--
well, we're going to fire
them out of this cannon
into this wood block wall.
Now, I'm not
concerned about what
your spears do to the wall.
I want to see how well your
spears survive the wall.
Drew, you're up first.
Are you ready?
No.
[laughs]
Well, we're
gonna do it anyway.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
That worked really well, Drew.
Despite the fact that you did
lose a little bit of your tip
in the kill test, it
didn't have any effect
going into that block wall.
Matter of fact, you sunk
all the way down here.
Very impressive.
Your shaft is fine.
Nothing loosened up.
Nothing cracked.
Your spearhead is still solid.
Overall, it survived.
Very good.
Thank you.
So, Jason, what
are you thinking?
Thinking let's make splinters.
[music playing]
That's a problem.
Oh, God, no.
I'm seeing it hang up
a bit on the barrel,
and my heart just
absolutely sinks.
Jason, we've got
a big problem here.
The parameters that we
set for these weapons
are for testing purposes.
Because your blade didn't meet
the inch and a half parameter
with a circular
cross-section, we cannot fit
the shaft of your
weapon down the barrel
of our testing apparatus here.
And because we can't
test it evenly and fairly
with Drew's blade, I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
This was absolutely
worst-case scenario.
I'm proud that I got
this far, but I'm
incredibly disappointed.
Well, Drew, in a competition
where attention to detail
is just as critical
as craftsmanship,
you are the Forged
in Fire Champion
and will be collecting
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
[applause]
Oh, my god.
Oh!
How you feeling right now?
I'm 18 years old, and I'm
the Forged in Fire Champion.
What-- what just happened?
Well, I think the best
blade just won, my friend.
Come over here and
shake our hand.
Oh, god.
Didn't want to win
this way, but I won.
And that's kind of
all that matters.
I started bladesmithing
seriously because of this show.
I learned all that I had
to learn to make it here.
And I just won.
This-- this is the dream.
Oh, my god, man!
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: Black
Beard's infamous cutlass.
Among the most notorious
pirates of the 18th century,
Blackbeard terrorized
Caribbean and Atlantic
merchant shipping with his
trademark cutlass in hand.
Its short but thick curved blade
featured a razor-sharp edge
that was ideal for
hacking and slashing
during close-quarters combat
while seizing small vessels.
In his legendary battle with
Captain Robert Maynard in 1718,
Blackbeard's cutlass
broke Maynard's sword
in half with a single blow.
Today, Blackbeard's
menacing presence and expert
swordsmanship can still
be seen in the video game
"Assassin's Creed IV--
Black Flag."
Bladesmiths, to test the
lethality of your cutlass,
I'm going to inflict
lethal wounds
on these ballistic dummies.
Jason, you're up first.
You ready?
I sure hope so, Doug.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
[chuckling]
All right, Jason.
You got a very big
handle here, but at least
it's got the swells.
It's got an indexing to
when I hold on to it,
I can tell where the edge is.
The weight that you have in this
weapon is so light in the sense
that I can wield it
even around here.
You cut the clavicle into
the ribs, all the way
through the lungs.
And, definitely, it will KEAL.
All I ever wanted to hear.
Made my day.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Seth,
you're up next.
You ready?
Get some.
[music playing]
All right, Seth.
Your sword is forward-heavy
without a balance coming back.
I don't know whose shoulder's
going to hurt more,
the dummy's or mine.
But your weapon, sir, will KEAL.
Thank you.
To test the strength and
durability of your swords,
I'll be chopping
through these bones
and then attacking that peg leg.
Now, remember, this test is
not about what your blades
do to these targets.
It's about what these
targets do to your blades.
Jason, you're up.
Are you ready?
Nope.
[laughs]
[music playing]
[sighs]
The balance of your
weapon is really nice,
which is surprising
because you've made
a two-handed cutlass.
Your blade held up very well,
except for the one little chip.
And it's not even a chip.
It's a roll.
So it didn't blow out.
It's a good job.
Thank you, Dave.
DAVID BAKER: All right, Seth.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Seth.
First up, this thing's a beast.
It is probably a pound heavier
than your competitor's sword.
Your blade-- I mean, I can
run my fingernail down this.
I can see a couple
of glinting spots,
but it really didn't
take any damage.
All right, bladesmiths.
Let's find out if
there's any edge left.
This is the rope cut
and pirate sail slash.
To test the edge
of your cutlass,
I will cut this rope,
which will raise the sail,
and then I will slash the sail.
This is all about
what your sword
will do to the sail and rope.
Jason, you're up first.
Ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
Arr-righty, Jason.
Your edge cut through
the rope easily,
and cuts with every
part that the edge
met on this pirate sail.
Overall, sir, your
sword will cut.
Awesome.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Seth,
how are you feeling?
Feeling good.
Let's go.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Seth.
What are the chances you
find a very dull spot
on the first cut on the rope?
But on the second cut, I had
found our spot that was sharp.
But on the sail, working
a heavy sword like this
affects my cuts.
Jason, Seth, the judges
have tested your weapons,
and they've made
a final decision.
The new Forged in
Fire Champion is--
Jason.
Congratulations, you're the
new Forged in Fire Champion.
Seth, unfortunately, your
blade did not make the cut.
Please surrender your blade.
Jason, congratulations.
You "arrr" our new
Forged in Fire Champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a bundle of bullion
that's worth 10 grand.
How you feeling right now?
[laughs] I mean, come on.
That's incredible.
Forged in Fire Champion?
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: The spiked shield.
Oh, [bleep].
WIL WILLIS (VOICEOVER): Dating
back to prehistoric times,
the shield is the oldest
form of protection, designed
to block attacks from
weapons like spears,
swords, axes, or arrows.
Over time, they
have varied greatly
in size and construction,
using material
such as steel, wood, animal
hide, and even turtle shells.
Used primarily as
a defense weapon,
the shield can also be used to
attack by punching an opponent
with either its face or rim.
Sometime around the
Middle Ages, spikes
were incorporated, adding
an extra level of brutality
to its design.
The long steel
spike could deliver
deadly blows,
oftentimes immediately
disemboweling the attacker.
The most notable
spiked shields today
can be seen in the popular
video game series "Skyrim."
Gentlemen, between the
13th and the 16th century,
spiked shields
were commonly used
by infantry to protect from
swords, spears, and arrows.
I'm going to fire three
bolts from a crossbow
to test each of your shields.
If your shield is strong,
it should deflect the arrow.
Ilya, you're up.
You ready?
Yes, I am.
[music playing]
I can see where
the bolts hit, Ilya.
Small impact there,
here, and right there.
Nothing that would even threaten
the man behind this shield, so
that's very well done.
Michael, you're up.
You ready?
I think so.
Let's do this.
DAVID BAKER: All right.
[music playing]
Yes.
Well, Michael, I
can see where one hit.
You have a bit of a dimple.
One impacted somewhere
on the center bust.
You could actually hear it.
[metal thudding]
And though there are
some cosmetic issues
with your shield, it certainly
held up to the strength test.
So, well done.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: Doug?
Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test.
With your shield, I
will take four hits
on this ballistics dummy
that's wearing chainmail.
Ilya, you're up.
Are you ready?
Yes, I am.
[music playing]
The shield feels
good in the hand.
I can maneuver in
different ways, not only
to protect, but also to attack.
Now, let's see how
much damage it did.
The killing blows
were right here, where
it penetrated all the way.
That's to the sternum
and into the lung.
In-- that is in the belly.
That goes all the way into
this ballistics dummy.
Your shield and the
spike will KEAL.
Mike, it's your turn.
You ready?
All right.
Mike, your spike's
a little bit loose.
Let's see how it
goes in the test.
We'll see.
[music playing]
Oh-ho-ho.
Mike, it feels
good in the hand.
You can strike with the edges.
You can accompany it
with the other hand.
It moves well.
The spike did hold up.
Now, let's see how
much damage we did.
All right.
God.
Your spike definitely
penetrated on both punctures.
Right here probably
where the diaphragm
is, and in the abdomen right
here, all the way through.
Your shield will KEAL.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, this
is the sharpness test.
I will attach your shield
to this mechanical device.
I will then release your
shield to see if it'll
puncture the steel drum.
If your spike is sharp,
it should go in easily.
If not, well, it may
just dent the drum.
Ilya, you're up.
Are you ready?
Yes, I am.
3, 2, 1.
Engaging.
Well, Ilya, your spike went
cleanly through the drum
and all the way out.
I don't see any problems or
any deformations on your spike.
So it held up very well.
Good job.
Thank you.
Mike, you're up.
Are you ready?
Oh, yeah.
Let's do this.
And in 3, 2, 1.
Engaging.
Phew.
Well, Mike, your spike
went all the way through.
Got stuck a little bit.
It came out cleanly.
But I do not see any
damage to your spike.
Good job, sir.
Thank you.
The judges have
scrutinized your work,
and they've made a final
decision about which of you is
the Forged in Fire
Champion, who will
receive a check for $10,000.
Ilya-- you are the
Forged in Fire Champion.
[music playing]
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Mike, your shield
did not make the cut.
Please surrender your shield.
Thank you, gentlemen.
This was a fantastic experience.
I think I performed very well.
So as much as I would
have liked to win,
this still feels like a victory.
Ilya, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire Champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
[applause]
Thank you.
The way that all
works together--
I mean, just fantastic
piece, I think.
I'm fairly satisfied
with the end result.
I might not often show it,
but trust me, I am proud.
The prize money is
already pretty much spent
on student loans
and my girlfriend's
education in astrophysics.
I'm the Forged in Fire Champion,
and it feels pretty good.
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: The
Landsknecht sword.
Created by Emperor Maximilian
I in the 15th century,
the Landsknecht were a
deadly mercenary force
armed with pikes,
swords, and crossbows.
The most battle-proven
Landsknecht
mercenaries were armed with
massive two-handed swords.
These imposing blades featured
parrying lugs above the guard
to deflect enemy attacks.
Earning double the
pay of their peers,
these garishly dressed
swordsmen of fortune
would rush headlong into
enemy pikes in an effort
to disrupt their
opponent's formations.
Today, you can see
the Landsknecht
sword in the hit mobile
strategy game "DomiNations."
Bladesmiths, the
two-handed German
Landsknecht sword's a big sword,
so we're expecting big damage.
I will take your
sword and deliver
slashes, thrusts, and chops
on this wild boar carcass.
Todd, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, I am.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Todd.
First up, your
handle construction.
It's comfortable to hold on to.
You have a very thick
and wide and stout edge,
so it's a chopper, not a slicer.
The big issue I have with this
is that it's a heavy sword.
But despite its
weight, it will KEAL.
Yes.
All right, DJ, it's your turn.
You ready?
Yeah.
[music playing]
DJ, let's talk
about your sword here.
It's even heavier
than the other sword.
The tip you have
over here is wide.
The first thrust went in.
The second one
couldn't, and I tried.
The one thing it did
was break its back.
A thrust like that, and a broken
back like that, will KEAL.
All right.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test.
And to test the overall
construction of your blade,
I'll be both stabbing and
chopping into this steel plate.
All right, Todd,
you're up first.
Are you ready?
Yes.
[music playing]
All right, Todd.
You took some pretty good rolls.
These rolls are fairly
deep, but it held up.
Nicely done.
All right, DJ.
You ready for this?
Yeah.
[music playing]
Oh, Lord.
All right, DJ.
This weapon is heavy.
Look at that balance point.
It's so far forward.
Keeping that tip up is brutal.
You've got a really,
really super stout edge,
and, honestly, it
held up quite well.
There are some rolls
here where it connected,
but the weapon's still solid.
It's a strong blade.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen, your
blades are still in one piece.
Now let's see if they
still have an edge.
To test that edge, I'll be
cutting through this cane.
Todd, you're up.
Are you ready?
Yes.
DAVID BAKER: OK.
[music playing]
[sword humming]
Hear that?
It sings.
It's like a tuning fork.
All right, Todd, so let's talk
about your singing sword here.
[laughs] You definitely
have a sharp edge here.
Sharp sword.
Made good cuts.
Well done.
Thank you.
All right, DJ.
You ready?
Are you ready?
That's a big one.
[laughs] I'm ready.
[music playing]
I can run my finger
along that edge.
On the first cut, as soon
as I hit the dull part,
it just starts
pushing stuff over.
Did a good job
putting it together,
but it's just not
sharp enough to cut.
Todd, DJ, you've both done
an incredible amount of work
to bring these
massive swords back
for our final round
of competition,
but there can only be one
Forged in Fire Champion.
And that champion is--
Todd.
Congratulations, you are the
new Forged in Fire Champion.
DJ, unfortunately, your
sword didn't make the cut.
Please surrender your blade.
My biggest regret
is I should have
spent more time on the edge.
I did my best.
And I didn't want
to build something
that was going to snap,
and I definitely did that.
Todd, congratulations.
You are the new Forged
in Fire Champion,
and that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job.
Thank you.
[applause]
Thank you, gentlemen.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
TODD: I'm a little surprised.
You know, it's still like
a surreal kind of thing.
I've proven what I've come
to prove-- that I'm capable,
that I'm still skilled.
And I'm thrilled that I
was up to the challenge.
I feel so good, I
don't know how to feel.
[laughs]
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: The bardiche.
Sweet.
WIL WILLIS (VOICEOVER): Vicious
and menacing, the bardiche
was a favorite of Eastern
European infantry soldiers
during the 16th
and 17th centuries.
Its large,
crescent-shaped ax head
measured nearly two
feet at the edge
and could cleave
through flesh and bone.
Specialized soldiers,
called streltsy,
would use the bardiche's
pole to balance their muskets
for firing from a distance,
then switch to their ax
during melee combat.
Though rare in
American pop culture,
you can experience
the bardiche's
savagery on the virtual
battlefield of the game
"Chivalry--
Medieval Warfare."
All right, bladesmiths.
This is the kill test.
To find out how
lethal your weapon is,
I will take your bardiche
and deliver lethal chops
on this pig carcass.
John, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
Nice!
Nice.
Right on, brother.
All right, John, let's talk
about your bardiche here.
I love the swells.
By putting these
swells right there,
it allows me to adjust my
hand and get a good grip
every time I move it around.
Your blade right
here is razor sharp.
It cuts through spine,
bones, and thick flesh.
Overall, sir, your
bardiche will KEAL.
I got something to show you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Sure.
A kill test?
DOUG MARCAIDA: Oh, it will keal!
[laughter] Good job.
I was hoping it'd KEAL,
because I had to do that--
I did that.
Well, good job.
All right, Michael.
Your turn.
You got anything to show me?
No.
All right.
You ready for this?
Yes, sir.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[music playing]
[breathes deeply]
Oh!
Nice.
[laughter]
All right, Michael.
This is at least around 11
pounds, all forward weight.
I waste so much
energy in recoiling
that could be used in attack.
But, overall, sir, your
bardiche will KEAL.
Yeah!
Oh!
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test--
the stump thump and steer smash.
To test the strength and
durability of your bardiches
as well as their
overall construction,
I'll be chopping
mercilessly into these logs
and cleaving that
steer skull in half.
Remember, this is all about
what happens to your bardiche
and not what happens
to the wood and bone.
John, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
Nice!
Awesome.
Well, John, your bardiche,
it's got a nice weight to it.
Not a huge fan of these
undulations in the
handle because I want to be
able to move my hands around.
I'm looking at the edge.
It held up beautifully.
Everything's still
straight and tight.
Good job.
Thank you.
Michael, you're up next.
You ready?
- Oh, yeah.
Hope you ate your Wheaties.
[laughter]
All right.
Oh, boy.
[music playing]
Oh.
All right.
[laughs]
Whew.
Well, Michael,
first things first.
This thing is heavy.
It's a beast.
But everything is still tight.
There's no motion in it,
even after all of that
chopping and smashing of skulls.
The edge held up really well.
So, well done.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Up next is the sharpness
test, and for that,
I'll give you to David.
All right, gentlemen.
Now, unlike the
strength test, this
is all about what your
blades can do to the target.
So I'm taking one shot right
down the middle trying to split
those watermelon, put
half in one bucket,
and half in the other.
All right, John.
Are you ready?
Let's do it.
OK.
[music playing]
MICHAEL: Nice!
[laughs]
All right, John.
It feels good.
It's got a good balance to it.
The shape of this
is really nice.
The cutting edge,
curved like that,
cut through the
watermelon beautifully.
Sharp weapon.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Thanks.
All right, Michael, you're up.
Are you ready?
- Bring out the beast.
- OK.
[laughter]
[music playing]
[breathes deeply]
Oh-ho-ho.
Well, right off,
it's definitely sharp.
But it weighs a ton.
I like the design of
this, but build strong
doesn't necessarily
mean build heavy.
John, Mike, you bladesmiths
have engaged in one of our most
difficult competitions.
However, only one of you can
be the Forged in Fire Champion.
And that champion is--
John.
Congratulations, you're our
new Forged in Fire Champion.
Mike, unfortunately, your
weapon didn't make the cut.
Please surrender your weapon.
MICHAEL: My experience here
was definitely a challenge.
It pushed me to my limits.
I learned a lot.
I might not be the
Forged in Fire Champion,
but I still feel like I'm
walking away a winner.
John, congratulations.
You're the new Forged
in Fire Champion,
and that is a title
that comes with a check.
For how much?
10 grand.
Please present your
bardiche to the judges.
JOHN: This is the most
mentally, physically,
emotionally stressful time, but
also the best time in my life.
Woo-hoo!
Forged in Fire Champion.
I'm super excited
to get home and tell
my wife about the great news.
And now the next
thing coming up,
I'm going to be having
a baby boy, so, I mean,
this is wonderful to hear.
Thank God.
[music playing]